ots o alto e quem fala é o dar que sejam
muito bem vindos a mais um vídeo e ou
estragos e quem falar em san francisco 4
que o segundo corre hoje estou aqui para
jogar em noite sim com aquela noite
todos temem a noite mas já deu o ok
vamos lá ver se estou a escrever embora
lá muitos de vocês disseram os
comentários que nesta noite vai pôr
serem porque minha câmera tabuchi
sozinho sacar e até agora nada quando
fred não sei se vai ser agora no início
ou não vocês não disseram isso esta
supostamente brasil e começa bem que nem
vamos outra vez houve alguém que estava
no catar eo rato show sozinho meu enxuto
não se no ratinho voltou para trás de um
vidro fechado a porta lá tá aqui eu já
fui chamada ataque não deixou primeira
música a eu não sei se vocês já sabem
que é um sentimento que sabem falar
alguma coisa e nem fretado não estatal
está baixa
o senhor e meu deus meu deus eu entrou
que como é que um intruso tinha a porta
fechada foi na volta a cair uma coisa eu
já percebi nesta noite só parece o
governo freire não parece mais ninguém
mesmo assim é difícil porque é graças a
ele eu não percebo como é que o vem eu
não sei se o vendedor mário era pele
pena capital em cada tempo ao barulho
o uso filho da mãe já possui o teu
esquema atuando lado a outra versão dx
11 e depois de ataques com deus - devido
à espera da faixa amor ainda está aqui
eu posso entender o já não não sei se
for eu não sei se ia eu vou tentar
tem a porta fechada e eu fui na volta
tenho certeza absoluta aguentei até a
uma já não é nada mau não começa já
daqui né
amanda volta por mário eu tenho certeza
que eu também aparece no armário tenha
certeza não cobra por ser de uma porta
que tá fechado meu mandato vem por trás
daquela é eu também posso vida que
supostamente estão fred e já não percebo
nada disto vai ai construir lento
paquerar
eu amo isso foi parceiro de volta por
aqui
filha da mãe de ana no novo méxico do
andrucha porta
ai eu não estava aqui seu nome já eu não
tenho nenhum
fui ver o pai da menina agora anda
pintou os parentes vão sair ok vamos lá
mais uma vez pessoal mais uma de várias
nem eu sei que vou levar muito tempo a
passar esta noite aí fui para a porta
errada da arquitecta e nem deu pra trás
na foto à esquerda num parque não tá
aqui eu tô aqui eu sabia que eu tenha
havido algum lugar a europa eo mundo à
europa onde mário a yoko fashion formar
e foi chamar eu
foi o que eu ame todo lado
ai meu deus de um ano em todo o lado
ae fui para outra porta que eu tenho que
tomar atenção aos passos do som por um
do sul mário então ficar no armário da
mãe é possível
ae
aí eu sou é mentira disse o padre thomas
foi bacana todo mundo
a carioca joga pelo esquema de lobby com
os gamers quinto filho também do urso e
eu em quatro lados e vai para as duas
portas vai pra cama e vai formar e eu
com sua maluca que não sou não é tentar
ao menos quatro coisas ao mesmo tempo à
procura de um funk em curso não está
aqui está virando um armário faixa roxa
no pac também ayew e ai ai
não dá
ok agora vai
meu deus fecha o michael donley can't go
aí não não faço pra outra
está aqui um saque em 5 é você e eu
foquei noite cinco fiquei que muito
tempo mas consegui caraças ok vamos lá
ver o que vai acontecer agora
ai meu curso
ok estamos o fim da festa estamos de
festa com fax e eu tenho que arrumar meu
a cair ou o teu irmão rei uma espécie de
bem não é
eu não sou eu nem consigo meu conforto
do ar sério e sujo tatá qualquer coisa é
hilariante
eu não quero ver mais um sério eu tô o
opera o que é que juntou a fazer um
estudo profundo tua visto que o homem
não quer chegar mais perto do gol de
fred para quem sugerisse minutos chu
lago neto bill deu o ae
este que movida é tão famoso mordida de
97 né 87 eu não sei meu deus tem uma
estrela é categoria fat freddy's da
ostentação quem tem gente que noite saí
genuity é extra por isso se quiserem ver
mais do fight night at freddy's deixou a
sua equipe jurídica para fazer isso em
um estádio para que vocês tenham
divertido ouvir homônimo entrar dentro
do milan chega do café bar que não cai e
fica bem até a próxima do gol
[Música]